تم الآن إزالة تمثالين آخرين بمناسبة مذبحة ميدان تيانانمن
من حرم جامعة هونغ كونغ ،
هذا واحد منهم ألق نظرة هنا ،
إلهة الديمقراطية نصب تذكاري لأولئك الذين
قتلوا في حملة عام 1989 ضد
المتظاهرين ، كما أزالت
السلطات دعامة العار في وقت سابق.  هذا الأسبوع
زعموا أن التمثال
يمثل خطرًا على السلامة ، وربما قُتل مئات الآلاف
من المتظاهرين في
المذبحة ، ويقول النقاد إن إزالة
هذه التماثيل هي علامة أخرى على كيفية قيام
الصين بقمع
الحركة المؤيدة للديمقراطية في هونغ كونغ
جينس جيلشوت الفنان الذي  جعل
تمثال عمود العار يتحدث معي ،
لذا كان عمود العار الخاص بك ينس
واحدًا من عدد قليل من
النصب التذكارية العامة لتكريم ضحايا
مذبحة ميدان تيانانمين ما هو
رد فعلك على إزالته ،
إنه أمر محزن حقًا لأن أه
لدي هذا  النحت هناك لمدة 25
عامًا وكان النصب التذكاري الوحيد أه على
أرض الصين أو من يتذكر
حملة القمع التي قام بها الرجل.
منحوتة مشهورة حقًا في
هونغ كونغ ونوع من الرموز
لهونغ كونغ هي هونغ كونغ وهونغ كونغ
لا تزال مكانًا تتمتع فيه بحرية
التعبير وعندما يأخذون هذا على هذا النحو
قاموا بتحطيمه تقريبًا في
ذلك الوقت  يشنون هجومًا على
الحركة الديمقراطية الديمقراطية وكل
الحق في التحدث في هونغ كونغ لذلك هذا
يوم حزين لهونغ كونغ على ما أعتقد